here to react is former head of the
arizona national guard and u.s senate
candidate retired general mick maguire
mick so nice to have you here on the
show this morning a lot of people are
saying of course that mark kelly the
senator of arizona is in big trouble
and that this is why
the president has approved this little
bit of wall in arizona to be
to be built you agree
good morning rachel i do agree this as
you mentioned is the height of hypocrisy
clearly this is a political stunt
that said every one of us in arizona
every one of us like me who has
generations of family here in this state
have never seen this level of
lawlessness you heard lawrence and brian
just talking before this that if you do
not enforce the rule of law
the country as we know it will come
apart at the seams and that's why i'm
running for u.s senate
and when people on the left rachel come
on your show and talk about it's
inhumane to build a wall ask them is it
inhumane to have over 40 people die in
the morales dam sector this year
crossing the border children
young children women
and and i'm telling you right now it is
completely lawless in this area this
sectional wall needs to get done but
remain in mexico needs to get reinstated
we need to reactivate the 1030 guardsmen
that were under my command that joe
biden zeroed out and my orcis is
derelict in his duty
you know mick there are some democrats
or at least one who's very honestly um i
think very a very honest broker about
the border and that would be henry
cuellar um he's been you know
challenging his party asking you know
biden and um and kamala to come down and
see what's going on has mark kelly done
any of those things and what is his
record as an arizona senator on the
border
well he's coming up on two years in
office shortly after he was elected in
the special election
he talked about the fact that he wanted
to study the problem
rachel i can take you down to the
morales damn sector today if we arrived
in the next hour within the next two to
three hours literally hundreds of people
would be streaming across dropping their
papers and entering their pockets before
they cross the gaps in the wall all
being trafficked by the cartels the
lawless behavior is escalated into human
trafficking
and escalation and drug smuggling china
is complicit with this in the production
of fentanyl precursors
hundreds of thousands of americans are
dying of overdose and literally mark
kelly says he wanted to study this
problem when he arrived in office yeah
that's the reason why they are terrified
the big money people are terrified the
establishment is terrified of my
success
taking him on in november because we
have to break this cycle
yeah well the u.s government's complicit
as well
thank you so much for joining us mick
and good luck in the
primary you bet everybody get out and
vote august 2nd tuesday is a big primary
and rachel i look forward to being back
on your show to talk about how a guy
that got out spent 12-1 wins this race
all right you got it thanks mick i'm
steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm
ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis